This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and soil sciences,
doctor of veterary medicine, four
post-doates and pathology, naturopathic
doctor.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
Bachelor of Science in Plant and Soil
Sciences, Doctor of Veterary Medicine,
for post-docctorates in pathology,
naturopathic doctor.
This program is for education.
Hello everybody and welcome to Daily
with Doc and Becca. I am your host and
producer Becca Dukes and today is one of
my favorite days of the week because
it's pharmacist Friday and let me tell
you today we came prepared with
questions that are sent in to us via
email. I want to say hello and welcome
to our live audience as they many of
them are here each and every Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday from 12 to 1:00 p.m.
Pacific, 1 to 2 mountain, 2 to 3
central, 3 to 4 Eastern. And folks, if
you're in another time zone, just use
your favorite browser
search engine to uh ask what time it is,
3 Eastern, in your time zone. So,
welcome, welcome, welcome everybody.
This program is being sponsored by
dailywithdoc and becca. No,
dailywithdoc.com.
Um, and if you were invited by somebody
specific, please get back with them and
tell them thank you. Thank you for
taking the time
to share this information with you. Now,
today we are loaded with questions from
our incredible community. questions
about medications, nutrients,
interactions, symptoms, side effects,
what's normal, what's not, and things
nobody seems to explain in those short
understandable answers like pharmacist
Ben does. Now, short, not always, but
that's okay because one he's when he's
done talking, we understand. So folks,
if you were in not invited by somebody
specific and you would like to speak
with a certified holistic health coach,
I do have a team standing by. For those
not already working with somebody, you
can reach them at 855-9493377.
So pharmacist Ben, he's amazing. He's
been practicing, well, he's been in
pharmacy quite a while and because he
looked more at the nutritional side of
things. Um, yeah, he got canned from one
of his pharmaceutical jobs. And I'm so
glad that he did because, you know,
whenever we have free rethinkers, people
that think outside of the box,
especially if that's a chemical box, and
looking more at the the neutrautical
side, the body just seems to function
better. Pharmacist Ben, am I wrong?
>> No, you're right. We have to exactly
what you're saying is we have to think
outside the box. But the irony is is
that we're outside the box. We should be
the box.
Outside the box should be the poisons
and the surgeries and the extractions
and the x-rays and the ablations and the
electrocutions and all the you know the
the strategies and the accutrants and
the devices that the medical model uses
to make us better which of course
doesn't do. Um and so we got positioned
as the outside the box. We should be the
box. You know, for eons, millennia,
millions, billions of years, there were
no doctors. We ate berries, we foraged,
and we didn't have diabetes, and we
weren't obese, and we didn't have heart
disease, you know, we had other things.
We we had we had traumas and infections,
of course, and that's really where the
medical model excels, and it has to get
credit for that. But aside from traumas
and um and infections,
we are the answer to the chronic
degenerative disease crisis that the
United that people all over the world
face, not the medical model. If you deal
with a chronic degenerative disease uh
symptom or issue or challenge whether
it's vertigo or psoriasis or heart
disease or dislycemia or whatever it is
the solution is not medical and
the most important challenge or the most
um the most um uh
the hardest challenge we'll say is
mental because we don't trust ourselves.
We automatically think somebody knows
better about our bodies than we do. I
always get a kick out allergy testing.
That always cracks me up when somebody
wants to get allergy testing. It's like
we are so disassociated from our bodies
and how our body responds to milk or
peas or eggs or whatever that we're
willing to let somebody take our blood
out of our body and go over to another
room and take our blood and put it into
a dish and then put a little milk or a
little egg or a little soy in the dish.
and then we're in the other room saying,
"Hey, over there, what's it say about my
body?" You know, that's basically what
an allergy test is. And that's the
classic example of how disassociated we
are from our bodies and from our
symptoms and ultimately from from um the
the the ways that we can recalibrate uh
our our our biochemistry even given the
fact that the body is an automatically
recalibrating system and homeostatically
adjusts autom without us even having to
think about it. So we got to start to tr
while it's true that the obviously the
medical model cannot handle the uh the
kinds of the kinds of uh issues and
challenges that it's being confronted
with the real problem is mental. We got
to believe in ourselves and we got to
trust ourselves. And that's why I've
said it before but I asked Dr. Wallock
one time what why he called the company
American Longevity and he and that
before it was Young was American
Longevity and he said I love the idea of
longevity health and I love the idea of
America. you can do it yourself. And you
know, that's the meme anyway. That's the
story about the United States is that
you can pick yourself up by your
bootstraps and you can do it yourself
and you don't need to have somebody be
your authority. No kings, you know,
there's this no kings thing now and it's
political,
>> but really no kings, there's a there's
an application to the the idea of no
kings in terms of health as well as in
politics. No kings. We're our own health
authorities, authors. We write our own
health potentially. Now, if you give up,
you advocate, you give up
responsibility, then you get what you
get. And and personally, I wouldn't do
it. That's my that's not my
recommendation. That's why we're all
here.
>> Okay. So, there's a couple things that I
wanted to point out. One,
the sol the you have a medical condition
and the solution is not medical.
>> No, you don't have a medical condition.
You have a lifestyle condition. Medical
conditions are breaking your leg or okay
getting getting an infection. That's
those are medical conditions. The vast
majority of our health challenges which
are heart disease, dislycemia,
neurological issues, autoimmunity,
digestive, etc. Those they're they're
framed medically by the medical world
because that's how they get their power
and they get their money, but they're
not really medical. They're lifestyle.
You can change your digestive, you can
change your Crohn's disease by not
eating. You can change your dislycemia
by changing how you the kinds of uh
foods you put in your mouth. You can
change your neurological conditions by
oxygenation. And unless there's some
kind of you know some kind of
degeneration, by oxygenation, by
exercise, by meditating, by slow deep
breathing that's how we want to look at
this. And that's why I say it's mental.
It's a perspective. We want to change
the perspective of our health issues
from being something that you have to go
outside of yourself and I don't say we
have to. You we have the opportunity to
you do whatever you want to do. We have
the opportunity to take these conditions
that are apparently and ostensibly only
a doctor can fix you and take them back
into into our control because it doesn't
work. I mean I'm not just saying this
just to say it. It doesn't work. How
many people out there have gotten relief
from their psoriasis or their heart
disease or whatever it is by taking a
drug? Now keep in mind you can get
apparent relief. You can take a beta
blocker and your blood pressure will
drop. That is true. But that ignores the
fact that the body is a network. It's a
web. You know you know what the
butterfly effect is? You ever hear the
term the butterfly effect? A butterfly
flaps it South America and somebody
catches a cold in China. because
everything linked you know the we didn't
know everything was linked when the
medical model started and it really it
behooves us to understand a little bit
of the history you know the medical
model started it was a it was miraculous
because before the medical model started
in the middle ages in the high middle
ages and the enlightenment in like the
1400s and 1500s they didn't know how the
blood circulated they they thought
disease was caused by the number nine no
lie that was what they thought at least
some people thought the disease was
caused by read a book on on medieval
medicine a long time ago go three causes
of disease with the number nine uh evil
clouds and little elves that shot arrows
at you. That's what they really thought
disease was caused by. So obviously when
the medical model came and said no there
are causes and there's diagnosis and
there's names and there's different
organs and they're all you know there's
ways that you can control these things.
That was considered a miracle. But
in 1940,
500 years after the medical model
started or thereabouts,
systems theory began. Systems theory was
actually a u a branch of physics that
was started to for people to be able to
understand how systems work. This idea
of systems, body is a system. And one of
the hallmark signs of a system is
everything's connected. You can't
isolate the heart and you can't isolate
the pancreas and you can't isolate the
brain. They're linked. The brain is
connected to the heart and to the
pancreas and to the digestive system. So
then the question is what do you do if
it's all networkked like that? You work
holistically
rather than reductionistically. You look
at the whole system and the whole system
has as one of the one of the concepts in
systems theory is their leverage points.
Any system has bottlenecks and leverage
and that's one of the pillars of systems
theory. And the leverage points in the
body are the digestive system and the
metabolic system and to a certain extent
the what I call the adrenal fibroid
complex. These are the three major
leverage points in the system called the
body. The heart is not a leverage point
in the sense that
you can't work on the heart by itself,
but you can work on the digestive system
by itself and you can work on the
metabolic system, but you can't work on
the heart, the brain, or the skin
independently. But the leverage points
allow you to do all that. And that's the
main point. That's that's the the the
story that we want to tell is that there
are leverage points that we can work
with that will allow us on our own
without intervention, without waiting in
line at the pharmacy, without insurance
companies, without having to say you
take my organ out. I don't know what the
heck to do. And that's why we're here
every day and why I'm here every week is
to explain and teach to talk to people
about how you can access your body
through the leverage points on your own.
And I think that's one of the most
powerful messages anybody could ever
tell or stories anybody could ever tell.
>> I agree and I appreciate you being here.
And it's the second thing that I wanted
to talk about because I was actually on
the phone this morning with a client. We
were talking about allergy testing. How
>> ironic.
>> Okay.
>> Um but this is with a this is with a
child.
>> This is with a child.
>> Seven years old.
>> Okay. So So
>> so what's so they want to go to have
allergy testing done? Well, she has to
have she's had episodes in the past
where
>> allergy of allergies
>> needed an EpiPen. So, there was shrimp
and sesame seed.
>> What kind of allergies? Like what
happened? They they couldn't breathe.
They ate a food they couldn't breathe.
>> Food allergies where she broke out and
everything started swelling up and she
couldn't breathe. They had to Okay.
>> take her to the
>> So, what's the point of an allergy test?
They're They know the They know there's
certain foods that she can't eat. So,
now they're going to go somewhere else
to have it confirmed. But it's crazy
because she was able to eat eggs and
loved eggs and then all of a sudden
>> sometimes that happens having eggs in
baked goods.
>> First of all, just because the symptoms
of an allergy occur doesn't necessarily
mean it's an alert. It's a true allergy.
It could be histamine as we've talked
about before. Histamine comes out of the
comes out a lot of places, but one of
the places it comes out is the gut, the
intestine. And so I don't know why this
person would have an allergy test done
because you just told me they have
allergies. So they know. So what's the
point of an allergy test?
>> Well, schools
and they want to make sure that she's
not getting them as snacks.
>> No, no, but they know she's allergic,
right? They know that she ate whatever
she ate and she broke out. So why would
you go have a test
>> there? She's the test. No, because the
the school wants
>> school wants some kind of validation
documentation.
>> Okay, documentation. Okay, I get it. But
so that and I understand that. But other
than that, do you see how we eat a food,
we break out, but then we'll have an
allergy test. And and I'm not trying to
make anybody wrong here. I'm just saying
it's an interesting idea that we don't
trust ourselves. We don't believe we
have the knowhow. And that's why I say
it's mental. You got to believe that you
can do this. We can all do this. We can
do this ourselves. And that's why I
think the most important thing that we
do on these programs is not nutrition,
it's not health, it's empowerment. We
want to give people their power back.
Right now, the power is being taken away
from us and it's being put in the hands
of the government. It's being put in the
hands of the doctors. It's being put in
the hands of institutions. And it's
always the institution against the
individual. Historically, institutions
are there for themselves. They're not
there for the individual. the the the
the assistance they give the individual
is ancillary.
>> It's an it's just it's a side effect.
The institution is not there for the
individual. It's there to perpetuate
itself. And that's why you have you know
we have the American Heart Association.
And ever since the American Heart
Association happened, heart disease has
gone through the roof, right? So we have
these institutions that are supposed to
be able to help us, but they're not
there to help us. They're there for
themselves. The word institution comes
from the Latin root stit.
Stit means static. Stays the same. An
institution stays the same. It doesn't
die. Institutions don't get cancer.
Institutions don't have children.
Institutions don't bleed red, they bleed
green. We have cancer. We have children.
We have bills. We have a life.
Individuals have different interests
than institutions. And if you're
expecting an institution to take care of
you as an individual, you're barking up
the wrong tree. It ain't going to work.
And the worst of the inst in my opinion,
the most egregious um uh offenders
of the institutions is the medical
institution, the institution of
medicine. And while they certainly have
done miracles with with antibiotics and
with with um with surgical procedures
and they can stitch things back on that
are mind-blowing and they do face
transplants and you know you hear that
lady who's m the monkey ripped off her
face and she had a face transplant
incredible things heroic things and they
deserve credit for that but it's crafts
work. It's not metabolic.
They're wonderful with crafting with
with techn with um as as technicians
as artists but it's not metabolic.
Metabolism is ours. We own metabolism
not the institution. Metabolism is an
organismic phenomena. The artistry of
surgery and it is an art. It's an
amazing art and the technology of
surgical procedures that is theirs and
they're wonderful. You're not going to
do surgery on yourself, but you can
change your metabolism on yourself with
something as as simple as breathing.
Something as simple as drinking water.
Something as simple as as using as using
your Beyond Tank Tangerine. And that's
to me is the most powerful message we
can tell, especially if somebody's
dealing with a health challenge. I've
been talking I know I said this before,
but I've been talking to a guy with
Parkinson's disease now for a couple
years. And he's a new man. He's a And I
didn't do any drugs. I didn't tell him
what I just told him to breathe. I told
him to use I26. I told him to start
taking some supplements and nothing.
Just simple stuff. But we had to
believe. Okay, that's my soap box.
>> That's it.
>> We have to believe and we have to
realize that even simple stuff
can make a huge difference.
>> Yes.
>> So, since we're on the topic of
allergies, uh Renee is wanting to know
if I'm allergic to sulfa antibiotics,
then I need do I need to worry about
eggs because they are sulfur? No, that's
a very good question and it's a very
common question. Sulfur
is not sulfur.
Chemistry, every syllable, every letter
counts. So sulfur sounds like sulfur,
but sulfur is a class of antibiotics
which many people have problems with.
Sulfur
is
an element on the periodic table and a
very very important element. Sulfur is
fiery. Sulfur used to be called
brimstone.
>> You ever hear like fire and brimstone?
>> That's sulfur. Sulfur is a very fiery
explosive element
>> and consequently it has tremendous value
in the body. In fact, arguably it's, you
know, I hate to say the most important,
but there is a case that could be made
that it's the most important mineral in
the body because it gets transferred
into a an electronic carrier called
sulfate.
And sulfate
delivers tremendous amounts of
electronic energy to molecules.
Specifically, it delivers energy that
will allow certain fatty molecules to
travel through the blood very
effectively. So sulfate is incredibly
important. It's produced at least
partially by the sun and it comes from
sulfur which even though it's in the
soil as it turns out many people are
deficient in because of soil
deficiencies and soil depletion. So
sulfur is is is uh non-negotiable.
It's not an optionable not an option uh
non-optional element. Uh now we get
sulfur from meat and if you most people
are meat eaters you get sulfur from eggs
and from high protein foods but um
taking nutritional sulfur is a
highly advisable in the form of MSM.
MSM is nutritional sulfur and the
interesting thing about MSM is
completely non-toxic.
>> Wonderful. Now, uh, just to continue,
she said she's done a lot of food
minimizing, but there's still something
that is flaring.
>> What does food What does food minimizing
mean?
>> So, she's eliminated a ton of food.
Pharmacist,
>> but she's still breaking out working
with her.
>> Okay, good. Okay. Has she fasted? Has
she fasted?
>> She has done a little bit of fasting.
When you're having a pro, when you're
having a problem, assessing what it is
that's causing the issues. It may not be
an allergy. It may be leaky gut
>> and toxins coming in from bacteria. It
could be SIBO. It could be a lot of
things that look like they're allergic
reactions if you're not familiar with
what an allergic reaction is. That's why
fasting is pretty much the best thing to
do because then when you start eating
again, you'll notice things more
clearly. So, if you're having a problem,
nothing's hard. Admittedly,
but if you're having a problem
pinpointing specific issues, um, and
you've you've done food minimizing or
food elimination, I assume she means,
fasting is really something you're going
to want to do. As hard as it is, as
difficult as it is, and even fasting for
a couple days.
>> What about for those who when they fast
their blood sugar dumps like
>> Well, yeah, that'll happen. That'll
happen. when you're fasting, if if your
body's under some kind of stress and you
fast, you don't want to you want to lay
in bed, you want to relax, you want to
chill, you don't want to put any stress
on the body. So, if you're trying to
fast and do your day and you go about
your errands and do go to work, etc.,
that could be a bit of a problem because
you're not you may run into issues with
cortisol and with low blood sugar, etc.
So, you want to fasting is not bad, but
you don't want to put a lot of stress on
the body while you're fasting. Now, some
people don't have that issue, especially
younger people. But as we old and as we
get older and as the impact of
degeneration kicks in, it may be a
problem. So, just chill. Lay in bed.
Just do nothing. And you should that
that if you still have a problem and
you're laying in bed and you have high
blood sugar, then you have another you
have a whole another uh health challenge
that you got to deal with. But for most
people, just don't do anything. Just
relax. Take the day off, which you know
is not a not a bad thing.
>> There you go. pharmacist been for
president or something high in power
because we're gonna get hot tubs and
we're gonna get days off for fasting.
>> Yes. Yes. Exactly.
>> Fabulous.
>> And you know that's I say that if we
really cared about health, that's what
we would do. We'd have national hot tub
insurance, national massage insurance,
national fasting insurance, national,
you know, days off. We don't care about
health. It's not true. We care about the
money that you can make from health. And
that's why we have, you know, 25% of our
of our budget goes to health. Can you
imagine how much money we spend on
health? Trillions. Trillions with a T.
Not billions, trillions.
>> And people complain about the cost of
supplements.
>> And then people will complain about the
cost of supplements. But here's the
thing, and this is why, you know, it's
even worse. The situation is even worse
in Europe and Canada and Australia, is
the drugs are subsidized. you know, your
insurance company pays for them and they
have all kinds of deals that they make
with the drug with the government to to
have the taxpayer foot the bill. And by
the way, it's all taxpayers, me and you,
everybody, even if you're not taking the
drugs. So, you get a biologic, you know,
that costs the government thousands of
dollars a month and you don't even
notice it because your insurance company
and and and pays for it and your tax
dollars pay for it, etc. So, anyway,
it's not a good situation, but it's not
an unresolvable situation. It's
something we can we can address.
>> Okay. And just a quick little comment.
Uh Ann says that she had allergy she got
allergy tested when she was a kid and it
wasn't for food. She had hay fever,
which now she knows was a histamine
reaction. Thank you, pharmacist Ben.
>> Yes.
>> And she had to get allergy shots for
years and surprise, they did nothing.
Well, you know, you you you said
something earlier and I wanted to
address that about how the gal all of a
sudden she didn't have allergies and
then she had allergies and that and this
and this remind Yeah. And so this
reminds me of this concept this Ann was
this Anna you just talked to who just
>> No, the the the Ann is the one allergy
shots for years as a child.
>> So Ann an just reminded me of something
I want to tell you about the little
girl. Uh there's a concept in allergy in
immune immunology called load l a d load
immune load and that's a straw that
breaks the camel's back phenomena.
So your immune system can be thought of
like a camel or camel's back and then
you have mold and that sits on the
camel's back and you're okay. Then maybe
you'll have um uh some kind of uh
preservative food says on the camel's
back and then all of a sudden you have
milk and boom the camel's back will
break and it'll look like the milk but
really the milk you could have tolerated
if you didn't have the mold and you
didn't have the preservatives from the
food. In other words, there's a certain
amount you can tolerate. So with that
gal, that kid, who knows? She may have
she may be piling on immune immune
activators. Immune activators immune
activators. her immune system can ha
hand handle everything until she does
one more and then that th that breaks
the camel's back.
>> Oh, all right. I that's called immune
load. And by the way, anybody who wants
to read about these kinds of ideas,
there's a a lady named Sher Rogers, Dr.
Sher Rogers, and she's written a book
called Tired Not Toxic or Toxic Not
Tired. Tired, not toxic. How she I think
it's I think it's toxic not tired.
>> Yeah. and it's a great book and she goes
into all the stuff at length. It's it
came out in the 90s. Classic book.
>> Awesome. Well, we've got lots and lots
of questions and the next question is
going to go to AJ who has patiently and
patiently been waiting. Bar uh AJ,
what question do you have for pharmacist
Ben?
>> Uh Ben, always great to see you. I'm
just um
a couple of a couple of
thoughts that I don't want to get in
trouble. But you said ear
>> you whenever you say that
>> I'm preparing myself.
>> I don't want to get in trouble.
>> Don't be asking me any obnoxious
questions here that that trying to make
me call out anybody. Well,
>> okay. Well, I'm calling you out. You
said
>> we thought most people thought that
>> blah blah blah until
400 years ago.
>> 400 years ago. Yeah. 500 years ago.
>> But you had cultures 10,000 years ago
mapping out the whole body.
>> Yeah. That's right. Yeah. There was a
there something happened if you really
want to get into history and I love
history but something happened around um
the early middle ages I think it was not
sure when it was but a whole library was
burnt in Alexandria Egypt do you know
about this the burning of the library in
Alexandria
>> was
>> yeah and so a lot of wisdom was lost
and they could have been lost
intentionally nobody really knows the
story behind that but yes many many
years ago a lot of this stuff was mapped
uh Chinese medicine is amazing. They
didn't have the same metaphors that we
have but they you know there we still
use Chinese medicine effectively
ayurvedic medicine you know in India's
>> herbs when he was talking herbs
absolutely absolutely but a lot of
wisdom was lost when the medical model
came in the medical model started off
probably as a humanitarian effort but it
got codified and centralized when drugs
became a thing in the middle of the 19th
century the middle of the 19th century I
don't know I don't want to get too down
a rabbit hole. But to raise to raise
your po to to address your point, in the
middle of the 19th century, a miracle
happened. We figured out how to make
organic molecules.
>> It was actually the late 18th century
when they first did it. You know what
the first organic molecule, by the way,
was that they figured out how to make
and organic molecules of molecules found
in nature, found in the body. And they
didn't know that you can make those
things, actually make them in a factory,
>> vitamin C,
>> in a laboratory. No, not vitamin C. in a
laboratory. That was a that that
completely changed the whole landscape
because not only could you now make
things that they used to think were just
nature that only God could do, they
could actually make it in a lab. That
revolutionized everything, but now you
could sell them and the profit margin
was incredibly high. The first organic
molecule to be synthesized came was ura
and that was a entire re that
revolutionized chemistry and
revolutionized medicine. It was a short
jump then into extracting the active
ingredient from from willow bark for our
for pain and and gradually through the
late 19th century they started to figure
out how to craft organic molecules until
the early 19th century they said we got
a whole opportunity here to take these
organic molecules which at the end of
the day come from oil. It's all fossil
fuel derived and we could turn the oil
and we could turn the fossil fuels into
these little tiny molecules that we can
sell for a lot of money that will change
and not only that but really in fairness
that could change biochemistry and
change biology. This was an amazing
amazing idea and you know we talked
about this before how the turn of the
20th century was this crazy time when we
thought we could do anything. Also, you
got cars and electricity and organic
molecules. And so, the purveyors of
these organic molecules said, "Let's all
team together and centralize everything
and control everything." And that was,
you know, the advent of the modern
medical model. They they kicked out
people who didn't follow the rules, so
to speak, and they had schools that were
organized and followed curricula. And it
was a short jump from the curricula into
uh uh corporations telling the schools
what the curricula could teach.
the end of the at the end of the day now
we have we have so it but you're right
your point is well taken for thousands
and thousands of years there was no
organic drugs there were herbs and there
were foods you know and there were there
were modifications that some of which
were ridiculous but others were made a
lot of sense urvedic medicine makes a
lot of sense
but it's a real neat history to medicine
and I don't want to get into that
digression now but it's very cool
>> I'll let our leader go back to uh
helping some other folks.
>> All right, thank you so much, AJ. As we
got a little history lesson in there,
too, folks. Lots of information being
shared that you can use as empowerment.
So, a little bit for everybody, even the
history book. So, let's go to the next
question. And Wendy wants to know, "How
do you know when to stop doing a liver
detox?" She says, "I drink a detox tea
at night and get cramps."
>> Yeah.
Followed by
>> Here's the problem with so-called detox.
Okay? And I don't want to step on toes
and I don't want to offend anybody here.
That's not my goal. But just log I just
want to be logical. What's the best
detox? Not to put the tox in in the
first place.
>> Yeah. Not to put the tox in.
>> So that's the best detox. If you're
trying to take a a herb
to detox with,
what do you think happens to the herb?
You have to detoxify it. So if you're
taking bo or danal danaline root or
whatever it is to detox, now you got to
detox from the detox. So the best detox
is going to be not eating. The next best
detox is going to be sticking to thing
uh uh chelating.
is like a magnetic attraction.
Z uh things like zeolyte, bentonite
clay, and for some reason nobody talks
about this. Plantder derived minerals.
Plantder derived minerals are one of
nature's best detox and you don't have
to detoxify them like you do an herb.
So, you know, that's one thing we have
to really be respecting when we talk
about plant- derived minerals is they're
amazing for detox detoxification. You
know, we talk about dirty blood all the
time. Plant derived minerals clean the
blood. Vitamin C is a a detox molecule.
Vitamin E is a detox molecule. Um,
magnesium, copper are detox molecules.
Zinc supports detox. There's so many
ways to detox, but when you do an herb
and I know I I always get heat from my
herbalist friends and I love herbs and
I, you know, I've studied them and I had
a herbal pharmacy for many years, but
they got to be regarded as medicines.
Vitamin C is not a medicine. It's a
nutrient. Herbs are not nutrients.
They're medicines. And they're not like
drug like they're not as potent as
drugs. They're much milder, but they
don't
they they have to be purified
themselves. They're not innocent
bystanders like vitamin C or zealate or
planter derived minerals.
>> So pharmacist been with what
>> I'd have to see. I'd have to see what
she was taking. I'd have to see to
answer that G's question. I see she was
taking.
>> Okay. But herbs include nutrients. Well,
herbs have nutrients in them because
plants have nutrients. Yes, herbs are
plants. So, don't even call them herbs,
just call them plants, right? So, plants
are plants. They have all the nutrients
that that we have. Not all of them, but
a lot of them that we have, most of them
that we have. So, yeah, you're getting
nutritional value. But when you're
taking an herb, you're taking if it
tastes like an herbal capsule, right?
Imagine
>> usually the extract. Well, if you're
taking the liquid extract, you don't
know what you're getting, okay? You
don't know what's getting extracted.
That's a little different. You're
getting an extract like say you get a
glyceride, glycerin extract. That means
you're going to get the stuff that comes
out in glycerin, which is a certain
spectrum of nutrients that are in the
botanical, whatever it is. If you have
an alcohol extract, that's going to be
different. You have a water extract,
that's going to be different still. If
you have a propyline glycol or glycol
extract, that's different still. So, it
just depends on the kind of extract, but
you're not going to get everything. have
an herb, you get everything. But if you
have an herbal capsule and you imagine
just opening up the capsule, you get a
tiny little bit of herb. There's not
going to be a lot of nutrients in there.
Yeah, you get some, you trace amounts,
but it's not like you're going to get
nutritional value from that. A little
bit, you know? It's like, think of an
herb like a salad, right? Salad, you get
a bunch of nutrients, right? Take a
little piece of that lettuce. How much
nutrient are you going to get out of
that? Or a little piece of the spinach
or a little piece of the the c the the
carrot or whatever. That's what an
herbal capsule would be.
Okay, if
>> you eat a whole slew of herbs, then
you're going to probably get some good
nutritional value, but you know, you
can't do that. Herbs, by the way, plants
are not that easy to process for the
digestive system. You a lot of people
can't digest plant material.
>> So, with that being said,
>> so how do you know when to stop a liver
detox? That's I don't know. What's the
liver detox? What's the person taking? I
have to see.
>> So, it is a tea. It does include SA. Um
I don't I can't remember all the rest of
them, but we will actually
>> STA is a laxative. Uh it's probably not
a good idea to stay on a laxative for a
long period of time. And okay, that's it
sounds to me and that's one that's a
detox strategy. See, detoxification,
remember we talked about phase one,
phase two, and phase three
detoxification. There's different levels
of detoxification. There's level one
where the molecules manipulated in your
liver to make it actually makes it more
potent. There's another molecule.
There's another phase two where the the
molecules made easier to excrete and
then there's phase three which is the
excretion the elimination out of your
body bowel movement mostly. So senna is
a a laxative and that can help but you
don't want to stay on laxatives for long
periods of time.
>> I absolutely agree. Next question. So
Bruce has a neighbor whose son is
considering a kidney transplant. Says
Dr. Wallik says diabetes type one is
you're born with it. The neighbor has
been diagnosed was diagnosed at four
years ago and now he's taking the taking
the shots. Uh he's in his 40s.
>> What's the question? Tell me the
question. What's the question? And then
tell me a misdiagnosis.
>> Could type 1 diabetes or kidney
>> type 1 diabetes.
>> Could it be a misdiagnosis? I mean, why
would they ask that? I mean, diabetes
is a brand name.
>> It's not a real It's not really a
disease and it's not really a
biochemical process. It's a name.
It's a diagnosis. The biochemical
process is dislycemia.
Dislymia
refers to messed up blood sugar. It also
involves insulin resistance.
So insulin resistance and dislycemia go
hand in hand. They call that diabetes.
Type two diabetes is what most people
have. Type one diabetes
is a different form of dislycemia where
the the pancreas gets it becomes the
target of an immune immune attack. It's
an autoimmune disease.
Type two diabetes is a metabolic issue.
Type 1 diabetes is an immune condition.
Now there's a lot of overlap. Remember,
these distinctions are not clear-cut.
So, you want to kind of you don't really
want to worry about the distinction as
much from a a resolution standpoint.
Type 1 diabetes, because your pancreas
is being attacked, it doesn't make
insulin. So, that give you insulin. Type
two diabetes, your body doesn't listen
to insulin. Not that it doesn't make
insulin, it doesn't listen to insulin.
It gets used to insulin. So you can't
really give insulin for type two
diabetes until it gets reaches a certain
point where it doesn't listen to insulin
where there's no insulin just doesn't
have any effect. Then you got to crank
the insulin in the body. But here's the
problem. Insulin is a very powerful
substance. Very one of the most powerful
if not the most powerful. It's certainly
one of the most powerful hormones in the
body. Arguably the most powerful. And it
does many many many many many things.
And in fact, keeping your insulin low
is the longevity strategy. That's why
fasting is so important. You want to
keep your insulin low, not high. If you
get to a point where you have to inject
insulin, that's the exact opposite. Now,
you're driving the system. Insulin
drives things. It pushes things. It
makes things grow. They're actually
bodybuilders who will who are not
diabetic will inject themselves with
insulin to grow muscle. It used to be
farmers would give their animals insulin
to make them bigger. So insulin drives
chemistry. Our problem today with heart
disease, with cancer, with cholesterol,
with dislycemia is we're driving our
system. We're pushing the system. The
body wants to stand down. It doesn't
want to push. It wants to push for
emergencies if it has to, but other than
that, it wants to be calm. We've created
a culture where our biochemistry is
being pushed with hormones and with um
with uh sugars and calories and food all
the different ways we the chronic
ingestion of foods. We're pushing the
system. You want to live a long life.
You want to have a nice have a a high
quality of life via your your health.
Calm the f down. Chill. Relax. Insulin
revs things up. Cancer is a cancer and
heart disease and diabetes are three
main uh uh uh chronic degenerative
diseases. All diseases are pushing
energy of revving cholesterol. They want
to shut your cholesterol down. Why does
your cholesterol go up? Because
cholesterol is a it's one of the ways
the body builds things. So we're
tricking the body into building things.
We're sending the body all these signals
that for millions of years were signals
of growth. But we're not growing. We're
not going to the gym. We're not
exercising. We're not moving. We're not
foraging. We're not hunting woolly
mammoth and and and and harpooning
whales. We're sitting on our butts, but
we're sending the body signals to grow.
And that in a nutshell is really the
problem. And that's why relaxation
strategies are so important. Meditation
and sleep and parasympathetic
activation.
>> So the growth that's happening is not
>> growth. It's stimulation. It's not
growth.
>> It's not growth. If it was growth, it'
be great. We'd all be big and strong and
muscular and you know, we're not we're
all that all that energy that's supposed
to be used for growth is is in our guts,
in our bellies because it's not being
used for energy. So it gets re it gets
restored in the liver and in the and in
the ab abdomen
>> as fat
>> as fat as fatty liver or as abdominal
fat. So, okay. So, going back to the
question, we've got a 40-year-old man
who was diagnosed
years old.
>> Was it a misdiagnosis? Is that the
question?
>> Wanting to know if it was could have
been a misdiagnosis that it was type
>> I type one diabetes.
>> Type one. Yes. I'm sorry.
>> Yeah. I I can't tell I don't know the
answer to that. I can't tell you that.
But I can tell you work on your blood
sugar and working on your insulin
whether or not you've been it's type one
or type two
>> or none at all. And by the way, they
used to say type 1 diabetes is not
reversible. It is. They used to tell
you, "Oh, you're going to be stuck on
insulin the rest of your life." Not
true. The beta cells that make insulin
can um when you have type 1 diabetes,
they don't make insulin. They're the
ones that are subject to the attack.
Type 1 diabetes can be reversed.
>> All right. Thank you so much. And the
next question and then we'll go back to
AJ. Um, what is Ben's fantastic
knowledge on Epstein bar
>> immune system? Epstein bar virus is a
virus.
>> Viral infections are opportunistic.
Opportunistic viral infections occur
when there's an opportunity. That's what
opportunistic means. When the immune
system is weakened. People who get epsc
virus are usually in the hospital or
they're under a lot of stress or they
have some other coorbidity. It doesn't
just happen. So it happens to immune
systems that are compromised. Shingles
are the same thing. COVID was the same
thing. Viral infections in general occur
when there's an opportunity for them to
occur. And so Epstein bar virus needs to
be regarded as an immune system that is
weakened. See, strengthen the immune
system. Sugar is one of the main
weakeners of the immune system. Excess
calories can weaken the immune system.
Um uh drugs can weaken the immune
system. uh load can weaken the immune
system if there's load from other
places. So strengthen the immune system.
That's the key. Selenium is one of the
best nutrients for for strengthening the
immune system. And selenium has
antiviral properties. People get cold
sores for example or or um shingles.
Also vitamin C is probably the most
powerful of all the vitamins for the
immune system. So work on immune system
building is what you want to do by
reducing load that includes sugar and
calories. And then also I'm using
nutrients that uh support and strengthen
the immune system. That's my take on
Epstein bar virus. Also the sympathetic
nervous system, remember it's the
parasympathetic and the sympathetic
nervous system.
>> The sympathetic nervous system
shuts down the immune system.
Why would that be?
Why would the sympathetic nervous system
suppress immunity?
such
trying to protect the body.
>> Why would that be? Why would why would
it be associated with the sympathetic
nervous system? Because when the
sympathetic nervous system is activated,
evolutionarily speaking, you're running
from a tiger,
>> right?
>> Yeah.
>> When you're running from a tiger, does
it matter if you catch a cold?
>> No.
>> Who cares if you catch a cold? You're
running from a tiger. So, all the
reserves go into um all the energy
reserves go into running and away from
other things that are not necessary. The
immune system is deactivated by stress.
So, are you under stress? Are we under
stress? Of course, everybody's under
stress. A lot of stress. And by the way,
psychological stress is one kind of
stress. There's physiologic stress, too.
Sugar is a physiologic stressor, and it
will suppress the immune system. We
talked last week about food activates
the sympathetic nervous system. That's
an immune suppressant. Cortisol is your
sympathetic
nervous system that shuts down the
immune system. That's why when you have
a rash, you put cortisol or cort
hydrocortisone on your on your skin. It
shuts down the immune system. So for
Epstein bar virus, again, like we said
before, calm the f down, chill, relax,
use nutrients that support immunity,
remove immune load, and uh breathe. did
activate the parasympathetic nervous
system with things like muscle
relaxation, warm water, um, gratitude,
all the things we talk about. If if you
want to do one thing to stay healthy and
live a long life, it's figure out
everything you could do to activate the
parasympathetic nervous system and have
the sympathetic nervous system stand
down. You do need a little sympathetic
activity, by the way, because it gets
your butt out of bed in the morning and
gets you to do things, but for the most
part, you want to be more
parasympathetic. Calm down, relax. The
system under stress is a system that is
not going to be able to withstand
viruses and and um um bacteria and mold
and all the other things that it seems
like are are the causes of our problems.
Those are there's a distinction between
real causes and proximal causes.
Proximal causes the cause that you think
is the is the uh the the uh trigger that
you think is the cause. That's the one
you see, but there's a cause before. So
it looks like it's the it's the virus.
That's the proximal cause, but the real
cause is a an immune system that is
overloaded.
>> So, start with a healthy body brain and
heart pack, which has the ultimate
selenium in it as well, and go from
there.
>> Yes. Yes. Absolutely.
>> Okay. Okay. So, folks, if you've got
issues with your system not being quite
right and you've been told that you got
this Epstein bar thing, back with the
person that shared this program with you
and say, "Hey, get me on a healthy body,
brain, and heart pack. Let's start
there." And if you're not working with
somebody, you've never tried any of the
products that we're mentioning, you want
to get connected with a certified
holistic health coach, call 8559493377.
If you would prefer to use email, you
can always email info@ailywithdoc.com.
All right, AJ.
Hey, I got a I got a question in from
Cheryl
in Brooklyn. She's asking
a question that we've asked before. Uh,
pharmacist Ben, uh, what are the
benefits to the donor for donating
blood?
>> A lot of benefits. make more blood first
of all and you you um lower iron levels
um and you help other yeah you know you
help other people of course but clean
keeping blood they used to bleed people
for health iron is a prooxidant and it
can be associated with accelerated aging
not to mention tissue damage and even
heart disease and you're going to lose
iron when you give blood many people are
ma are not able to process irons as
effectively and they have too much iron
in the blood he hemocromattosis and such
and so um
you clean. You'll you'll get rid of the
iron, but you'll also get rid of
anything else that's in the blood that's
a problem. And your body will make more
blood, make more fresh blood.
>> Will you will you be handing
>> Absolutely.
>> Absolutely. Obviously, you will
>> someone else your problem.
>> Obviously, but they may not have the
same problem that you do, but yes,
anything in the blood will be in the
blood. There's a there are um molecules
in the blood called da d d d d d d d d d
d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d d
d d d d d d d d d d d ds dams
damps stands for damage associated
molecular patterns and these damage
associated molecular patterns are things
that get into the blood through a leaky
gut they're the cause of dirty blood
what I always call dirty blood I say it
somehow somewhat you know facitiously or
graphically so you can imagine it's not
really dirty blood but it's blood that
has contaminants in it from the from the
from the intestine there. Sepsis is a
major blood problem. Sepsis is is
bacteria in the blood, micro microbes in
the blood, and it's a serious problem.
But there's also something that nobody
ever talks about except we talk about
all the time called non-microbial
sepsis.
Non-microbial sepsis is an inflammatory
condition in the blood that is not
related to organisms. It's related to
damps and toxins from the intestine. So,
yes, to answer your question, those will
obviously come out, too. Yes, but they
don't check for those.
>> Okay.
>> I don't think they actually I should say
that. Maybe they do check. I don't know
the answer to that. They should. I don't
know if they do or not. So, I don't want
to say that, but they should.
>> Okay. You mentioned the word iron. And
then, uh, what about someone who's iron
deficient? What can
>> Iron? Iron deficiency is oftentimes not
really iron deficiency. Iron is tightly
controlled. It's tightly tightly
regulated because it's so powerful and
so oxidative. It it's probably the most
oxidative. Well, I shouldn't say that.
It's one of the most oxidative minerals
of all the elements. Fluoride is pretty
oxidative. Um,
so the body controls iron because you
need iron. Obviously, iron is how you
get oxygen. Iron's is an oxygen magnet.
That's how we get ox that's how oxygen
is delivered is through iron. Little
piece of iron and hemoglobin uh attracts
oxygen. And that's how your blood stays
oxygenated and that's how our cells get
oxygenated. So you need iron. So the
body controls it. However, that control
point is in the liver.
We have 130 140 150 million Americans
probably have liver problems, fatty
liver disease. And so a lot of people
are not processing iron correctly. And
that changes the iron levels. Either the
iron's too high or too low. If you have
an iron issue, more often than not, it's
not the intake of iron, it's the
processing of the iron. And that
requires focusing on liver health.
>> And
>> and the liver of course is part of the
triangle of disease.
>> And the liver and the liver is being
damaged by sugar and
>> fat, sugar, drugs, toxins in the air.
The liver is the liver is the most
phenomenal organ in the body. It does
thousands of different things, hundreds.
It stores amino acids and vitamins and
glucose. It detoxifies. It makes bile.
It makes hormones. It's just a just
phenomenal phenomenal structure and and
if you have fatty liver disease you're
going to be you're going to have a world
of hurt and one of the places you're
going to have a problems with possibly
anyways with iron.
>> I'm sorry.
So this this question that was asked
earlier about um liver toxins
um
>> about about the detox
>> the detox.
>> Yes. Yes. So
>> that can put it that can put a stress on
the liver, but it's certainly not like
the stress like sugar. And fructose, by
the way, is especially fruit sugar is
especially problematic for the liver.
And when I say fruit sugar, I'm not
necessarily talking about just fruit,
although that can be a pro problem
because today's fruits, modern fruits
have lots of fructose.
The real problem is with isolated
fructose as in high fructose corn syrup
which is used now as the major sweetener
in industrial foods because it's much
cheaper than sugar. So high fructose
corn syrup is a big problem.
Fructose as I said can be an issue
because it's it's processed in the liver
and fatty liver is oftentimes a fructose
issue as much as it's a glucose issue if
not even more. So fructose you got to be
really pay attention to not so much in
fruits although yes somewhat in fruits
but especially in high fructose corn
syrup and also fruit juices
smoothies Jamba juices they're
supposedly good for us.
>> Thank you Ben.
>> Thank you AJ.
>> Yes thank you great great question and
let's finish it off with this one.
Charmaine wants to know when someone
breaks out eating pineapple is that
because of histamine? Probably. Yes,
probably. The
uh pineapple is a is a I'm not sure if
it's a histamine containing food or a
histamine trigger. It's one or the
other. But yes, it could very well be.
It more than likely is. A lot of foods
that people are allergic to, citrus,
pineapple, etc. are are really not
strict allergies to the food as much as
their histamine responses, which you
know, for all intents and purposes is
similar. But you can take care of a
histamine response with things like
vitamin C and which is an antihistamine
and keretin and um diamine oxidase and
also patching up a gut. Not necessarily
with a strict allergy.
>> Okay. Well, pharmacist Ben, I want to
make sure that we get you out of here on
time. So, we got four minutes to shut
down so that you're not late for your
next appointment. And okay, do your
thing.
>> Thank you so much. Um, as we delivered a
lot of information that is empowering
for the individual, you don't have to
stand in line or create an appointment
for you. Get it right here on Daily with
Doc and Becca and Pharmacist Fridays
with pharmacist Ben Fuches and other
times and also
pharmacist bin Bites on Mondays usually
with Coach AJ where you can get more
information about that at fruit not root
no root notfruit
>> root
>> root notfruit.com
and also the triangle of disease.com
folks.
>> Yes.
>> But don't forget dailywithdoc.com which
is the sponsor of today's program and
folks get back with a person that shared
this program with you because they cared
enough about you.
Be considerate and tell them thank you.
If I could get our co-hosts up on the
screen with me, that would be absolutely
fantastic because I'm so thankful that I
do not have to do this with just myself
and pharmacist Ben. Um there's a lot of
working pieces and each of these
individuals are covering a couple of
them. So I wanted to say thank you
Marilyn as we lovingly call her speedy
fingers as she's doing a lot of
dictation and putting information into
the chat that's only available if you
are here live with us in Zoom. You can
register by going to
zoom.dailywithdoc.com dailywithdoc.com
and make sure that you are logged into
your Zoom account in order to register
and be admitted into the Zoom. So, thank
you Marilyn. We have Albert who's
joining us from South Africa and he is
our gatekeeper. So, thank you so much
Albert. And if you're calling in the
middle of the night in the United States
and you hear this amazing accent, that's
probably Albert.
Um, and then we have Phyllis, one of the
pioneers in spreading this message.
Thank you so much, Phyllis, as she's
putting more information into the chat
as well, plus keeping an eye on the
different platforms and bringing those
questions in. And we have our executive
producer,
um, which is Ruth Ellen.
He's
laughing at me. And don't mess with her.
>> You don't mess with her.
>> You don't mess with that. Executive
production manager.
>> That's it.
>> That's right. I'm the I'm the producer.
Oh my goodness.
>> You are the queen producer.
>> So this is stress. I I need Ben
as president so that I
>> hot tub insurance. National hot tub
insurance.
>> That's it. And I want a saltwater tub,
please.
Um, but yes, and Ruth Allen will come
and use it, too. So, double double duty
there. But, um, thank you so much, Ruth
Ellen, for all that you do. And last but
not least, we have AJ, who is our
digital marketing manager and helping us
to get on all the different platforms
and making sure everything is rolling
the way it's supposed to roll. So, thank
you everybody for joining us, being part
of the team and pharmacist Ben being one
of the leaders of our team. And if
folks, if you want to be part of a team
and you just have a heart for others,
reach out to the person that share this
program with you or call us at
855-9493377.
Again, that's 855-9493377.
be part of a solution
when it comes to empowering others.
Pharmacist Ben, closing remarks.
>> I can't hear you.
>> We can we can all do this. We can do
this ourselves.
>> Yes, we can.
>> There's no health challenge that's not
reversible. There's no chronic
degenerative health challenge that's not
reversible. By nature, the body can heal
itself, but it needs the raw materials
to do its work. We can help you
understand that.
>> Yes. Thank you so much. And folks, if
you want more information and you think
that you need to be a certified
something or another,
>> we do have a certified holistic health
coach course that you can get more
information on. Veryformational.
And it goes over the four areas of
health. It goes over Dr. Wallik's
teachings, how it applies to each and
every one of us from way back in the
early days to even now. You can get more
information about that at
coach.dwithdoc. dailywithdoc.com.
So until next time, thank you so much
everybody. Have a great weekend. And AJ,
do we have pharmacist Ben bites on
Monday?
>> You know what, folks? Go to
dailywithdoc.com. Make sure that you're
registered for our email list so that
you get notifications of when
stuff is happening.
>> That's correct. Awesome.
All right. Thank you again everybody for
being here live with us or out on the
different platforms. Please make sure
that you subscribe, comment, let us know
what you liked best and where you're
joining us from. So until next time, bye
for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
continue to share the teachings of a
founding father of the science of
epigenetics, Dr. Joel Wallik, Bachelor
of Science in Plant and soil sciences,
doctor of veterary medicine, four
post-doates in pathology, naturopathic
doctor